our meeting point wasn't easy to find we
arranged to meet a group of freestyle
bikers in the center of Kabul every
Friday the youngsters gathered to
practice in a small public park they
study the tricks and stunts on YouTube
pashka Masada founded the BMX club named
drop and ride the message is simple drop
the gun and ride a bike
waha Tekamah is jeonghwan / /
we're tired of war that's why I wanted
to do something different something cool
I love riding bikes and want to inspire
others I also want to do something to
promote gender equality in Afghanistan
that's why for several months girls have
been training with them 19 year old
Sarah Fozzy was the first she read about
the club on Facebook and asked if she
could join the guys agreed now there are
15 young women in the group riding
bicycle it mean to me that I'm free and
I can do anything and I have the equal
right with the men and it's like I'm
flying when I ride my bike yeah
training with a mixed gender group here
in the park is high-risk they often get
arrest or even attacked by hardline
conservatives who believe that women
riding bikes is prohibited by Islam but
the youngsters don't want to give in
they are trying to create an alternative
to the narrow-minded old-fashioned
traditions which so often make their
lives more difficult that doesn't mean
that they are careless they are afraid
of bomb attacks and because of the
ongoing hostilities they always ride in
groups Vera says she's afraid whenever
she goes out but fleeing from
Afghanistan isn't an option
together yeah not god this is our
country we have to rebuild it
nobody's gonna do it for us maybe I'll
go and study abroad for a while
but I'll come back straightaway to
support women in Afghanistan with what
I've learnt
the bike club also needs support its
founder ash guy built most of the bikes
himself money is always a problem that's
why the bikers are taking pictures for a
crowdfunding campaign they want to use
the money to build their own ramps and
inspire more boys and girls and
Afghanistan to also draw and write